I think that women's golf attire is the
sexiest of all sporting clothes I'm
putting out there I I would I I would
say above just just above field
hockey above just swimsuit beach
volleyball there's something about the
pleated skirt the shoes the little
Collard thing and the visor it floats my
boat oh I like it now starting to see
why you like playing golf
J I only ever play with men ever play
with women a couple times what are the
best men's uniforms oh for for sports
okay see this is we thing so the women's
golf attire is the best looking sporting
attire men's golf attiring is the worst
looking sporting attire yeah some of the
worst shirts I've ever seen all in the
same sport we're up and up
something and we're making something
brilliant